bonjour à tous vous allez pouvoir suivre
dans un instant l'examen et le vote de
la proposition de loi sur la lutte
contre la prostitution un texte voté
mais profondément modifié par le Sénat
puisque les sénateurs ont supprimé la
pénalisation du client et réintroduit
dans le texte la le délit de raclage un
vote qui a déclenché la colère des
associations mais aussi des politiques
Juliette mais Adel portent parole du
Parti socialiste à parler de régression
scandaleuse des propos repris par la
ministre de la santé des affaires
sociales Marisol Touraine le texte
devrait d'ailleurs être de nouveau
profondément modifié lors d'une deuxième
lecture à l'Assemblée nationale nous en
venons à présent à ce qui a été la
partie la plus médiatisée de cette PPL à
savoir l'interdiction ou non de l'achat
d'axe sexuel cette question à
cristallisée toute l'attention bien
souvent au détriment d'ailleurs du reste
de la PPL et je regrette avec la
majorité de mon groupe que la Commission
spécial nouvellement élu et confirmé ce
que l'ancienne Commission spéciale
d'ailleurs avait dit avait fait c'est de
supprimer cet article 17 alors pourquoi
est-il important pour moi comme pour la
majorité de mon groupe de revenir au
texte qui a été voté par l'Assemblée
nationale
comme chacun sait la France est depuis
1960 et la ratification de la Convention
des Nations Unies un pays abolitionniste
la République reconnaît en effet depuis
lors je cite que la prostitution et le
mal qui l'accompagne à savoir la traite
des êtres humains en vue de la
prostitution sont incompatibles avec la
dignité la valeur de la personne humaine
et mettent en danger le bien-être de
l'individu de la famille et de la
communauté il paraît donc indispensable
de mettre fin aujourd'hui à cette
violence que constitue la prostitution
violence car comment réfuter que celui
qui paye attend la pleine satisfaction
de ses exigences ça rejoint tous les
pouvoirs on en a beaucoup débattu les
témoignages recueillis durant le déjà
dit du Carlton ont d'ailleurs mis en
lumière cette réalité si les clients
décrivaient ces relations tarifaient
comme des parties fines entre amis ou
des pratiques libertines les mots
utilisés par les prostituées rentraient
eux dans le champ lexical de la violence
ce que nombre d'entre nous défendons
avec donc la réintroduction de cet
article c'est de faire entrer l'achat
d'actes sexuel dans la catégorie des
infractions pour marquer un interdit en
tant que violence extrême ne pas mettre
la pénalisation des clients c'est
tolérer ces violences sexuelles et
tolérer le fait qu'on fasse du corps une
marchandise un commerce les arguments
qui nous sont opposés portent sur la
difficile constatation d'un tel délit
sur l'aggravation de la situation pour
les prostituées sur la constatation
d'une certaine misère sexuelle à
laquelle la prostitution serait la seule
réponse et maintenant un nouvel argument
sur la notion de prostitution contrainte
ce qui sous-entend qu'il y aurait une
prostitution librement choisie alors
qu'on sait chiffre à l'appui qu'elle est
extrêmement minoritaire donc on va
légiférer sur la généralité ou sur
quelques cas isolés l'exemple de la
politique menée depuis plus de 15 ans en
Suède est utilisé par les pro
pénalisations comme d'ailleurs par les
Antilles toujours est-il que le
commissaire au sein de la brigade
antiprostitution de Stockholm que nous
avons écouté en audition affirme son
efficacité notamment sur les mentalités
aujourd'hui les socialement inacceptable
d'acheter des prestations sexuelles en
Suède 70% des Suédois sont favorables à
la loi et ce soutient est
particulièrement fort chez les jeunes
preuve que la loi peut faire bouger les
mentalités peut travailler les
mentalités il est impossible à mon avis
de réellement s'attaquer au système
prostitutionnel et à toutes les
violences qu'il engendrent sans
pénaliser l'achat d'actes sexuels donc
sans dire une bonne fois pour toute que
les clients font partie ce système
prostitutionnel Jean-François Corti
directeur des missions France de
Médecins du Monde
affirmait dans l'humanité de ce jour ce
n'est pas parce qu'on aura pénalisé les
clients que les prostituées auront à
manger dans leur assiettes certes c'est
vrai mais qu'est-ce qu'on attend par
cette loi c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui il
y a un certain nombre d'experts qui
disent non il ne faut pas pénaliser
l'acte sexuel tarifé comme si ça devait
répondre à toutes les questions qu'on se
pose au travers de la réalité de la
prostitution il ne faut pas faire dire à
cette loi plus qu'elle ne veut dire elle
marque des jalons elle marque déjà long
pour mettre fin à ce système et pour
considérer tous les protagonistes comme
des acteurs à part entière et refuser de
faire entrer effectivement les clients
dans le système prostitutionnel c'est
réfuter toute la réalité de la
prostitution alors quand j'entends il
nous faudrait un peu plus de temps pour
travailler mais qu'est-ce qu'on pendant
tout ce temps au Sénat enfin on a eu on
a eu plus d'un an pour travailler avec
deux commissions spéciales et moi j'ai
l'impression qu'on travaille au Sénat
alors il est question à mon avis là
autant dire les choses d'un vrai
désaccord et d'une volonté politique de
faire ou de ne pas faire c'est pourquoi
je trouve très important de soutenir
cette proposition de loi telle qu'elle a
été votée au niveau de l'Assemblée
nationale et je pense qu'il faut
vraiment réfléchir à aux actes que l'on
commet au niveau de du Sénat avec ce
qu'on vient de faire à une voix près de
réintroduction du délit de raccollage là
on en rajoute et on vit totalement la
loi de toute sa substantifique moelle
merci Madame Laurence Cohen Madame
Catherine Génisson avait demandé la
parole également
on discute de l'article 16 alors que
pour l'instant il est il est toujours
supprimé c'est pour cela que je ne
mettais pas inscrite plus vite pardon
c'est le règlement ah bon
je croyais qu'on discutait sur des
articles quand ils étaient dans le texte
mais là il est pas
on n'a pas on n'a pas voté des
amendements le rétablissant enfin c'est
pas grave moi je cela me permet de dire
d'ailleurs que je veux remercier
chaleureusement bon notre président
actuel de la commission spéciale mais
bien évidemment celui qui l'a présidé
pendant tous les travaux que nous avons
mener depuis l'année dernière
jean-Pierre Godefroy et notre rapporteur
Michel Meunier et je voudrais dire que
la la qualité avec lesquelles ils ont
mené les débats sont à la hauteur de la
gravité du sujet qui qui nous occupe et
j'ai envie de dire qu'ils ont mené
vraiment les débats de cette commission
spéciale faisant en sorte de nous faire
réfléchir des sans jamais nous
influencer et j'ai envie de dire que
quand on voit les positions divergentes
de notre rapporteur et de notre
président jean-Pierre Godefroy cela
illustre le fait que je pense tous les
membres de cette commission spéciale ont
tous eu la même exigence la même
obligation de lutter contre ce qui est
un mal social
dramatique la traite de en fait des
personnes l'esclavage moderne et la
lutte contre les réseaux et la lutte
contre la prostitution quand on le sait
aujourd'hui effectivement ce sont 97%
des femmes qui sont des femmes
étrangères et qui sont j'allais dire
importés dans différents pays pour
satisfaire ce qu'il y a sans doute de
moins honorable dans notre société mais
en même temps si vous voulez il faut
dire aussi que nous avons auditionné
comme cela a été dit les minorités
celles et ceux qui se revendiquent du
travail du sexe il faut les respecter
ils sont respectables pour autant je
n'ai pas comme d'ailleurs l'évoquer dans
son propos liminaire madame Jouanneau
retenu le principe du respect de la
liberté je l'ai entendu j'ai entendu cet
argument mais ce n'est pas cet argument
là que je retiens pour exposer ma
position je suis profondément engagée
engagé pour lutter contre les dégâts ça
a été décrit par beaucoup d'entre nous
de la prostitution sur les femmes que ce
soit les dégâts physiques que ce soit
les dégâts psychologiques que ce des
dégâts sociaux je suis engagée à 200%
pour lutter contre tout cela mais j'ai
beaucoup études écouté au cours de notre
commission spéciale toutes celles et
ceux qui sont dans le combat comme nous
pour lutter contre les dégâts et les
dégâts dramatiques les dégâts qui
peuvent aller jusqu'à la mort cela a été
dit de ces femmes de ces femmes
prostituées toutes ces personnes qu'elle
soit issues du monde de la sécurité du
monde de la justice et plus encore
peut-être du monde de la santé j'étais
particulièrement sensible à celles et
ceux qui sont exprimés au nom du monde
de la santé j'ai il y a eu le témoignage
Laurence Cohen évoquait le témoignage de
du président de Médecin du Monde mais
j'ai été très très marquée par le
témoignage de cette cellule d'homme de
femmes de l'hôpital Ambroise Paré qui
depuis 25 ans lutte contre les dégâts de
la prostitution et toutes ces personnes
nous ont dit ne prenez pas cette mesure
ne prenez pas cette mesure parce qu'elle
va rendre ce qui a ce qui a été évoqué
par beaucoup d'entre nous les femmes les
plus précaires parce que ce sont celles
qui sont dans la rue ce sont celles qui
sont dans les bois ce sont celles qui
sont vraiment dans les conditions les
plus précaires de d'exposition on va les
rendre plus contestés on va les rendre
plus en visibles on va les rendre plus
solitaires on va les rendre enfin plus
plus enfin rendre leur métier à exercer
encore plus difficile et en plus le
client qui pourra effectivement se
sentir lui-même plus en danger aura des
pratiques encore plus inacceptables il y
aura des exigences en matière terrifères
encore plus acceptable c'est ce que nous
avons entendu de façon une année alors
j'entends bien de grandes personnalités
médicales comme le professeur Axel Kane
comme le professeur israélisant qui
se prononce pour la pénalisation du
client j'ai envie de dire qu'ils ont un
avis tout à fait respectable mais qui je
suis pas sûr qu'ils étaient au cœur du
dispositif qui ils étaient au cœur des
maraudes j'entends beaucoup plus et je
suis beaucoup plus interpellé par la
position de Xavier Emmanuelli dont on
sait qu'il a lui participer nuit et jour
et jour et nuit au combat au combat qui
nous qui nous réunit aujourd'hui mais
vraiment moi ma position si vous voulez
elle est basée sur la recherche de
l'efficacité de l'efficacité absolue et
je n'ai pas été je ne suis pas convaincu
que le fait de pénaliser le client soit
une mesure efficace non seulement je ne
pense qu'elle n'est pas forcément
efficace je pense qu'elle peut être
contre-productive alors me direz-vous il
faut trouver des solutions je n'ai pas
voté le retour du délit de comment du
délit de raccollage qui a été proposé
par un amendement de notre président
avant la fin de séance mais je pense
vraiment qu'il faudrait que il y ait des
moyens parce que bien sûr il y a nous
sommes tous les uns et les autres
d'accord sur le sujet de la
l'accompagnement social de leur
insertion des femmes prostituées mais je
pense que c'est un problème de
responsabilité d'engagement d'engagement
budgétaire d'engagement aussi au niveau
humain pour toutes celles et ceux qui
sont partis prenantes de la lutte contre
la prostitution qu'il faut mettre en
place avec beaucoup plus d'énergie
encore même si le gouvernement actuel
fait beaucoup d'efforts en la matière
pour lutter contre les réseaux et je
pense aussi que c'est une contre les
réseaux ne doit pas se situer uniquement
au niveau de la France mais là peut-être
au moins ce pourrait être un dossier
européen qu'il conviendrait traiter
merci Madame Génisson
alors je suis saisi de trois amendements
identiques
un amendement numéro 3 rectifié qui est
présenté par Madame Cohen
il est défendu parce que je l'ai
développé dans mon propos merci Madame
Cohen le numéro 12 rectifié bis par
Madame meunier
madame Lepage oui merci monsieur le
Président beaucoup de choses ont déjà
été dites mais laissez-moi préciser un
petit peu le la visée de cet amendement
l'article ayant été supprimé l'article
16 ayant été supprimé par la commission
spéciale le présent amendement propose
de le rétablir tel que voter par
l'Assemblée nationale en première
lecture
cet amendement rétablit donc le
quatrième pilier de la proposition de
loi qui vise à la création d'une
infraction de recours à la prostitution
d'une personne majeure punie de la peine
d'amande prévue pour les contraventions
de 5e classe il prévoit également la
récidive
contraventionnelle de ces faits alors
puni d'une amende de 3750 euros la
progressivité de ce dispositif pénal
tente à accompagner un changement
sociétal on interdisant l'achat un acte
sexuel considéré comme une violence cet
article est indispensable à l'équilibre
et à la cohérence du texte de loi il
réaffirme clairement la position
abolitionniste de la France et permet
d'affirmer concrètement que nul est en
droit d'exploiter la précarité et la
vulnérabilité ni de disposer du corps
d'autrui pour lui imposer un acte sexuel
par l'argent la prostitution est un
phénomène sexuel qui contrevient au
principe d'égalité entre les hommes et
les femmes en effet si 85% des 20
000 à 40000 personnes prostituées en
France sont des femmes
99% des clients sont des hommes
dans les années 2000 les personnes
prostituées sont à 90% des personnes de
nationalité étrangère alors que cette
proportion n'était que de 20% en 1990
principalement originaire de Roumanie de
Bulgarie du Nigéria du Brésil et de
Chine ces personnes sont le plus souvent
maintenues sous la coupe de réseau de
traite et de proxénétisme organiser et
violent les personnes prostituées sont
victimes de violence particulièrement
graves qui portent atteinte à leur
intégrité physique et psychique comme le
démontre les études réalisées sur ce
sujet
ce constat heurte plusieurs principes
fondamentaux de notre droit en premier
lieu le préambule de la Convention des
Nations Unies pour la répression de la
traite des êtres humains et de
l'exploitation de la prostitution et le
l'exploitation de la prostitution
d'autrui du 2 décembre 1949 ratifié par
la France le 19 novembre 1960 la
prostitution et le mal qui l'accompagne
à savoir la traite des êtres humains en
vue de la prostitution sont
incompatibles avec la dignité et la
valeur de la personne humaine et mettent
en danger le bien-être de l'individu de
la famille et de la communauté
en Suède je sais que parler de la Suède
fait bondir plus d'un dans cette
hémicycle mais en Suède ou en
application de la loi du 4 juin 1998
modifiée par la loi du 12 mai 2011
l'achat d'actes sexuel est puni d'une
amende et d'une peine d'emprisonnement
la prostitution de rue a été divisée par
deux en disant d'autre part rien indique
que la prostitution dans les lieux
fermés est augmentée du fait de
l'interdiction ni que des personnes qui
se prostituent autrefois dans la rue ce
soit replié dans des lieux fermés pour
exercer cette activité il n'existe pas
non plus de preuves démontrant
l'existence d'un lien entre la
pénalisation de l'achat d'actes sexuel
et la hausse des violences subies par
les personnes prostituées contrairement
à ce qu'avant certains opposants à la
présente très fort
arrive monsieur le Président
en posant les règles relatives à
l'interdiction de l'achat d'actes sexuel
cet article propose d'agir pour la
première fois sur la demande comme étant
responsable du développement de la
prostitution et des réseaux
d'exploitation sexuelles c'est un signal
fort au réseau du proxénétisme nous
faisons le pari qu'on attaquant la
demande la proposition de loi dissuadera
efficacement les réseaux proxénètes
d'investir sur un territoire dont les
législations sont moins favorables au
profit criminel enfin cet article
responsabilise le client et renverse la
charge de la preuve qui pèse aujourd'hui
sur les personnes prostituées par le
biais du délit de racolage que nous
venons de rétablir
madame Jouanneau sur le 31 rectifié
est-ce que nous choisissons de conserver
la législation actuelle ou est-ce que
nous évoluons vers la pénalisation du
client sachant que ici dans une très
grande majorité personne n'est pour le
règlementarisme conserver la législation
actuelle ça a été efficace sur la
prostitution dites traditionnelle c'est
à dire faire peser la présomption de
culpabilité sur la personne prostituée
puisque cette prostitution dite
traditionnelle effectivement est en
train de disparaître par contre ça a eu
un effet pervers c'est que ça s'est
accompagné ça même favorisé finalement
le développement des réseaux et donc la
prostitution sous contrainte d'où la
nécessité de faire évoluer notre
législation la réalité de la
prostitution c'est que les personnes
prostituées ont la tous dit on l'a tous
reconnu sont d'abord des victimes donc
il serait logique et cohérent que notre
droit le reconnaisse et qui cesse de
faire peser la présomption de
culpabilité sur ces personnes
deuxièmement je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
pour un client
qui va rencontrer une personne
prostituée dans le bois de Vincennes
quand on connaît les conditions
d'exercices on peut pas imaginer une
seconde que ce client en toute sincérité
puis dire non je savais pas non non
manifestement elle était consentante et
ça lui fait plaisir donc le client a une
part de responsabilité face à cette
forme de prostitution et il est logique
que l'on inverse effectivement la charge
de la preuve et en inversant le droit on
met le droit du côté des personnes
prostituées alors oui Jean-Pierre
j'entends bien ta remarque sur la
pénalisation du client qui a recours à
une personne prostituée sous contrainte
et je pense que si chacun était prêt ici
à faire un pas à faire un peu de
co-construction c'est un mot à la mode
on pourrait effectivement aboutir très
simplement un sous amendement qui
intègrerait cette dimension de sous
contrainte dans l'article 225 12-1
je propose je crains que ce soir les
positions ne soient un peu figées et que
au delà du débat qui jusqu'ici est très
serein et plutôt je trouve très
responsable en réalité on n'arrive pas à
faire bouger les lignes mais je le
propose quand même
merci Madame Jouanneau
la vie de la Commission
oui monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre donc c'est un
amendement qui a fait beaucoup discuter
et qui en est encore la preuve ce soir
donc à titre personnel j'ai déjà indiqué
que j'étais favorable à l'instauration
de cette nouvelle infraction en effet
cette incrimination permettrait comme
saint-amandres certains membres de la
commission l'ont défendu ici de
renverser la charge de la preuve et de
souligner enfin que la personne
prostituée n'est pas la responsable de
l'acte de prostitution en plaçant le
client comme partie intégrante du
système prostitutionnel l'objectif est
de diminuer la demande et d'agir sur
l'offre
cette sanction de l'acheteur même
relativement modérée à une forte portée
symbolique et pose clairement le
principe qu'il est inacceptable
d'acheter un acte sexuel cependant la
commission spéciale a considéré dans sa
majorité que les inconvénients qui
s'attacheraient à une telle infraction
pourrait être trop important donc la
Commission a ainsi choisi dans sa
majorité de confirmer la position
qu'elle avait déjà prise en juillet
dernier refusant à nouveau la création
de cette nouvelle contravention donc
c'est un avis de la commission spéciale
qui est défavorable
merci madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président j'aimerais
apporter quelques quelques points de
précision parce que je crois que ce
niveau du débat nous avons besoin d'être
précis et notamment de faire référence à
des textes extrêmement précis la Suède a
effectivement adopté le 4 juin 98 1998
une loi qui rend passible d'une amende
et d'une peine de prison toute personne
qui se procure des services sexuels en
échange d'une rétribution ou d'une
promesse de rétribution quelle que soit
la forme que prend celle-ci la peine de
prison d'une durée initiale de six mois
a été portée à un an en 2011 un rapport
d'évaluation portant sur l'interdiction
de l'achat des services sexuels publiés
en novembre 2010 par les autorités
suédoises dressent les constats positifs
il était donc une évaluation de 99 à
qu'est-ce qui est noté dans ce rapport
extrêmement précis la prostitution a
diminué
et la prostitution sur la voie publique
en Suède a chuté de moitié depuis 99
rien ne permet de conclure que celle-ci
est conduit à un report de la
prostitution vers les lieux fermés et
que cela est conduit à une plus grande
précarisation des personnes prostituées
la loi ne paraît pas avoir conduit les
personnes prostituées à refuser toute
forme de coopération avec les services
de police à l'inverse il semble que
leurs paroles se soient libérées du fait
du changement de regard que porte sur
elle la société alors que deux tiers de
l'opinion publique étaient opposés à la
pénalisation du client avant l'adoption
de la loi cette proportion est
aujourd'hui inversée en particulier chez
les jeunes en 1996 67% de la population
était défavorable à la pénalisation de
l'achat d'actes sexuel 71% y était
favorable en 2008 outre une diminution
significative du nombre de personnes
prostituées la réforme suédoise a permis
de modifier la perception du phénomène
prostitutionnel par la population ces
éléments
puisqu'il faut apporter aussi un renfort
de personnalités qui sont indiscutables
ces éléments ont été confirmés par
Madame Nissan chef du Parquet
international de Stockholm et Madame
Anna charrette
chancelière de chancelière de justice en
Suède auditionné en France par la
commission spéciale de l'Assemblée
nationale et le Haut Conseil à l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes madame
listam a notamment indiqué que les
écoutes téléphoniques menées dans le
cadre d'enquête judiciaire portant sur
les réseaux de traite mettent en
évidence l'intention des chefs de réseau
de quitter le territoire suédois car les
trafiquants estimaient qui étaient
devenus trop difficiles d'exploiter des
femmes à des fins sexuelles en Suède et
que le marché était désormais jugé
inhospitalier j'ai rencontré
personnellement les ministres des droits
des femmes suédoises
elles font ce bilan très positif en
s'appuyant sur ce rapport du
gouvernement suédois certains comme cela
a été dit laisse entendre que la
prostitution cachée aurait augmenté mais
les enquêtes policières menées sur les
crimes liés à la prostitution et la
traite n'étant rien ces affirmations et
il n'appartient pas à mon gouvernement
de faire planer le doute sur un rapport
produit par un gouvernement démocratique
membre de l'Union européenne et c'est ma
source sur ce sujet d'autres pays
d'autres pays ont changé leur
législation ou sont en train de la
changer depuis 2009 les législations
identiques à celle applicable en Suède
soit entrée en vigueur en Norvège et en
Islande en Norvège à l'automne 2013 la
majorité des parties du gouvernement
nouvellement élu et conservatrices a
souhaité abroger ou assouplir la loi
criminalisant l'achat de services
sexuels mais sur la base d'un rapport
pour prendre cette décision et bien au
vu de ce rapport il a été décidé
finalement de ne pas revenir sur la loi
puisque les conclusions sont que comme
en Suède la loi norvégienne a
vraisemblablement engendré une évolution
des mentalités et les conclusions du
rapport montrent notamment une réduction
de la traite au Canada il vient
d'adopter le 6 octobre 2014 une loi qui
sanctionne l'achat d'actes sexuel en
Irlande du Nord examine aujourd'hui en
ce moment pardon un texte législatif qui
est prévoit aussi la pénalisation des
clients de prostituées c'est pour vous
dire que nous ne sommes pas seuls à
réfléchir à ces sujets que d'autres ont
produit de nombreuses de nombreuses
études et rapports pour faire évaluation
et des perspectives pour leur nouvelle
législation je voulais vous apporter ces
éléments parce que je pense qu'ils sont
aussi extrêmement importants il est
normal d'ailleurs que nous puissions
nous nourrir des réflexions d'autres
pays qui nous entourent qui sont au sein
de l'Union européenne avec nous pour que
nous puissions aussi légiférer dans de
bonnes conditions en tous les cas sur
les amendements qui ont été présentés
j'amène évidemment un avis très
favorable
merci Madame la Ministre alors madame
blonda demander la parole pour
l'explication de vote
le président et bien madame la ministre
vous avez évoqué évidemment le cas de la
Norvège parce qu'il faut regarder autour
de nous dans tous les pays de l'Europe
et au-delà parce que nous sommes pas les
seuls à réfléchir et à débattre sur ce
sujet or effectivement la Norvège a
décidé de pénaliser le client et je
voulais apporter également un témoignage
sur la loi qui est actuellement en cours
au niveau du Canada et qui stipule la
prostitution fait apparaître le corps de
la femme comme commodité pouvant être
achetés elle porte ainsi préjudice à
toute la société en transmettant le
message que les actes sexuels peuvent
être achetés par ce qui le veulent par
ceux qui possèdent argent et pouvoir
elle a des effets négatif sur les
collectivités dans lesquelles elle est
pratiquée en raison des actes criminels
annexes et je voudrais bien rappeler que
justement les proxénètes recherchent
essentiellement l'argent le crime pour
obtenir de l'argent et je rappelle ce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure en
discussion générale c'est quand même le
trafic le plus important qui va générer
évidemment des bénéfices pour aborder le
terrorisme et autres ventes d'armes donc
là je crois que véritablement nous avons
ici un symbole un interdit à poser la
loi pose un interdit et nous devons le
faire ça une valeur symbolique c'est une
valeur réelle aussi sur nos jeunes je
crois qu'on n'a pas beaucoup évoqué la
situation de de nos jeunes mais s'il
voit regarder un petit peu ce se passe
dans nos écoles primaires vous avez
certainement des exemples dans des
écoles primaires ou des garçons des
petits garçons très souvent ce livre a
des harcèlements et de type parfois
sexuel auprès de leurs de leurs
conditions et ça c'est quelque chose
d'absolument
extraordinaire et à bafouer et à
évidemment
je trouve plus le terme parce que je
suis assez troublé par ça je viens de
lire dans un dans un la presse
quotidienne qu'une jeune fille de 19 ans
dans la région Ouest de la France a été
condamné pour avoir incité deux plus
jeunes à faire à faire de la
prostitution à se prostituer moyennant
donc finance et le jugement vient de
d'être fait la semaine passée donc je
crois que nous avons un signe à donner
en faveur de la de la jeunesse et c'est
à nous législateur de pouvoir le faire
de montrer cette interdit
merci Madame Blondin madame Benbassa
merci monsieur le Président je vois que
l'argument principal des abolitionnistes
et le succès que ce dispositif aurait
remporté en Suède or la réalité suédoise
n'est pas aussi rose qu'on veut nous le
faire croire et en tant que scientifique
je vais vous dire que je suis choqué par
la manipulation des chiffres dans cette
assemblée
chacun colporte les chiffres de l'autre
qui sont quand on regarde les sources
ces chiffres ne sont pas exacts bon et
je crois que cela ne relève pas de
l'honnêteté intellectuelle
en juillet 2012 et oui monsieur
Kaltenbach les scientifiques ont une
certaine honnêteté intellectuelles voilà
en juillet je ne dis pas que tout le
monde n'est pas honnête en juillet 2012
l'ONU constaté que depuis son
application en 1999 la loi suédoise
n'avait pas amélioré les conditions de
vie des personnes prostituées mais les
avait au contraire aggravés selon la
police le commerce sexuel dans la rue a
diminué de moitié en Suède comme l'a dit
madame la ministre mais globalement il
reste au niveau qu'il était avant la
promulgation de la loi et il est devenu
en grande partie clandestin il s'est
déplacé dans les hôtels et les
restaurants ainsi que sur Internet et au
Danemark selon les services suédois de
la police judiciaire il est devenu plus
violent le même constat a été établi par
la Belgique qui a pour cette raison
renoncée à pénaliser les clients selon
le rapport produit à la demande du
gouvernement suédois en décembre 2013
par le Conseil administratif du comté de
Stockholm en 2014 alors je vous donne
les chiffres c'est un rapport qui est
sorti en suédois et qui vient d'être
traduit alors je vous donne en anglais
et je vous donne les chiffres
oui d'accord madame bon
depuis
1995 le nombre de prostituées femmes
dans les rues abaissées de 650 à 200 250
en revanche le nombre d'escort-girls est
passé et la prostitution chambre lui de
3004 à
6965 et j'ajoute c'est toujours dans ce
rapport qui a été commandité quand même
par le gouvernement le nombre d'hommes
prostitués est passé de 190 à 702 la
mesure envisagée entraînerait donc des
risques de violence accrues un accès
beaucoup plus difficile à la prévention
aux soins médicaux les associations
auront plus de mal à rencontrer les
prostituées pour leur proposer les aides
et services que leur fournissent
aujourd'hui un article paru dans la
revue
très scientifique de l'ancêtre en
janvier 2015 souligne les effets
dévastateurs de cette précarisation
sanitaire spécialement pour les plus
démunis qui exercent selon dans les
forêts sur les aires d'autoroute etc
dans des conditions d'hygiène plus que
doutesuses à quoi il faut ajouter une
soumission plus forte au proxénète qui
disposent de studio d'appartements ou de
structures d'accueil où les prostituées
se rendront après avoir pris rendez-vous
avec les clients et encore plus marqué
selon les risques d'acceptation des
demandes de certains clients par exemple
les rapports sont préservatifs les
étrangères migreront dans des pays où le
client n'est pas pénalisé ce qui ne
Soustra pas ces femmes à la prostitution
celles qui resteront en France à savoir
les traditionnelles ou occasionnels
devront pour garder le revenu actuel
entrer davantage dans la clandestinité
soyons pragmatique soyons surtout
avec la pénalisation des clients cette
proposition de loi loin de protéger les
prostituées et d'atteindre l'objectif
qu'elle affiche aggravera encore la
précarité de leurs conditions
lutons-nous contre le proxénétisme qu'on
le contre le mal organisé ou contre les
prostituées je vous le demande cette loi
qui était abolitionniste au départ avec
le rétablissement du délitoracolage et
devenu prohibitionniste jusqu'où
irons-nous pour la vertu que nous
voulons appliquer à notre société notre
société pourrait écouter les personnes
prostituées ce qu'elle disent c'est nous
qui d'une manière despotique leur disons
comment régler leur vie sexuelle merci
et je m'arrêterai là
merci Madame
merci monsieur le Président
nous voterons une grande majorité contre
ses amendes
pourquoi parce que nous sommes
majoritairement contre la pénalisation
du client pourquoi
la Constitution va devenir de plus en
plus clandestine les bosquets les
camions les herbes autoroutes et là dans
des lieux lointain sordide où les
prostituées seront mal protégés et à la
merci des des mafia et des boîtes qui ne
sont pas des gens
problème
d'hygiène et de sécurité
deuxième chose
la loi Estelle des outils sociales parce
que qui va-t-elle frapper
est-ce qu'elle va faire frapper les
émirs les oligares que les joueurs de
football professionnel de haut niveau
les clients des palacent parisien
et ceux qui se plaient des escort-girls
à paraît-il 1000 euros de l'heure et
plus bon d'un côté vous aurez cela qui
serait intouchables et on fera de la
poursuite de pénale pour le porc au bout
le poids malheureux qui se fera prendre
au bois de Boulogne ou ailleurs
ben écoutez c'est mon avis vous y passez
pas je vous donne mon avis troisième
chose le droit pénal pour moi n'a pas
intervenir dans le domaine des pratiques
sexuelles entendues consentants
c'est c'était l'adulte a le droit de
dire son corps par contre les problèmes
qui se posent c'est les problèmes des
des réseaux des proxénètes et des mafia
à Paris nous avons actuellement
une brigade de répression du 22 du point
qui est de 50 personnes
50 policiers il serait plus utile à mon
avis de poursuivre les mafia que de
poursuivre les Portugais et les clients
donc pour moi cet article de cible et
donc je répète nous ne voterons pas
c'est la vendeurs merci Monsieur Ruquier
madame Gauthier
je voudrais évidemment ces amendements
évidemment on sent bien qu'on est là
avec cette question de la pénalisation
sur un des cœurs de la proposition de
loi je voudrais dire à cet instant que
je ne reçois pas le procès d'intention
que l'on nous fait qui consistera à nous
dire que dès lors que nous sommes pour
la pénalisation nous ne respectons pas
les personnes prostituées c'est
absolument le contraire mes chers
collègues voilà je crois que la ministre
a donné des éléments d'appréciation sur
l'évolution des législations dans notre
pays et que peut-être notre difficulté
c'est de sortir de posture
préétablie vous le savez la France a
choisi d'être un pays abolitionniste
je crois qu'elle a eu raison de le faire
parce que cette question de la
prostitution encore une fois a bien
avoir avec la question de l'égalité
homme-femme comment peut-on prôner
l'égalité et ne pas respecter et
considérer qu'on peut acheter un vagin
ou le louer voilà je brutalement parce
que c'est quelque chose qui me
scandalise particulièrement mais
manifestement le chemin va être long et
je crois qu'il y a un travail très
important à faire en direction de la
jeunesse et avec cette question de la
pénalisation nous souhaitions avoir un
effet pédagogique posé dans la société
un interdit la moitié de l'humanité ne
peut pas considérer qu'elle peut louer
une partie du corps de l'autre humanité
ce n'est pas comme ça que l'on peut
construire des rapports de de d'égalité
alors moi je voudrais quand même revenir
sur plusieurs idées reçues que je viens
d'ailleurs d'entendre redire ce soir et
par exemple le fait que je voudrais
préciser que pour moi
ces idées reçues relèvent d'une
construction culturelle et sociale et en
aucune manière de quelques effets
naturels que l'on est qu'on hériterait
ainsi le fait que ce soit mal nécessaire
répondant à des sexuelle irrépressible
que les personnes prostituées le veulent
bien voir qu'elles aiment leurs
activités et que c'est de l'argent
facilement gagner je crois que c'est
tout à fait le contraire et je voudrais
vous rappeler un témoignage qui
personnellement m'a beaucoup choqué qui
est celui d'inspecteur de ligase qui
nous ont dit que dès le dès le
secondaire on constatait des relations
sexuelles tarifiées en échange d'argent
ou de cadeaux avec pour cette situation
de prostitution de très jeunes le fait
même qu'il n'avait pas conscience de se
livrer à la prostitution et donc
évidemment la question de l'éducation à
l'éduc à l'égalité dès le plus jeune âge
la question des ABCD de l'égalité que
nous avions en notre temps
particulièrement soutenu à la délégation
ne paraissent tout à fait avoir leur
place dans le débat que nous nous menons
ce soir parce que je vous rappelle que
le code de l'éducation prévoit deux
types de formation qui peuvent se
rattacher à cette logique l'éducation à
la sexualité qui prévoit trois séances
par an dans les écoles les collèges et
les lycées et la formation l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes que qui
prévoient de dispenser à tous les stades
de la scolarité sans plus de précision
sur les horaires et les niveaux de
l'enseignement le problème est c'est que
c'est l'essai à l'arbitrage des chefs
d'établissement ce qui veut dire que ça
n'existe pas dans tous les
établissements et que donc tous les
élèves n'ont pas accès à cette à cette
connexion sur ces questions là voilà je
voudrais dire quand même pour en
terminer que on va sur peut-être pas
voter cette cette disposition je le
regrette profondément mais je voudrais
quand même dire ma collègue madame
Génisson que sur la question des dégâts
ça me choque un peu ce qu'elle dit
Madame Génisson vous me choquez parce
que le meilleur moyen de ne pas faire de
mort à la guerre et bien c'est de ne pas
faire la guerre
merci mesdames Gontier Merin la parole
est à Monsieur Godefroy
madame la ministre ce sera très bref
j'étais frappé dans les débats
par le fait que l'on laisse entendre que
la loi aurait eu des effets très
positifs en Suède
j'ai repris un rapport qui ne peut pas
être suspect c'est le rapport de la
Fondation cell ça m'a alerté ça m'a
inquiété ça concerne ça concerne la
Suède on y lit ceci à la page 524 la
prostitution masculine en plein essor et
tiens et donc j'ai regardé ce qu'il y
avait des cris et ça m'a inquiété quand
on parle justement de la pédagogique de
la loi puisque là-bas la palisation du
client ça date depuis 1998 on y dit que
dans une enquête réalisée par le Conseil
national de la jeunesse en Suède
sur 2254 jeunes suédois paru en novembre
2012 2,1% des jeunes suédois entre 16 et
25 ans et 08% des jeunes suédoises ont
indiqué cette prostituée au cours de
l'année 2012 soit au total ce serait
environ 20 000 personnes et il écrit de
plus les jeunes sont aussi clients
car la moitié des clients des personnes
prostituées de moins de 26 ans ont
eux-mêmes moins de 26 ans
et on lit cette tranche d'âge se montre
donc particulièrement tolérante à la
prostitution avec 21,9% des personnes
interrogées notamment les garçons
trouvant acceptable que leur père et des
relations sexuelles moyens rémunération
donc je m'interroge sur le sur le sur
l'aspect pédagogique parce que malgré
tout 2,3 2,1% d'une population d'une
classe d'âge c'est pas mince bon si je
tenais à rappeler cette état de fait
maintenant concernant madame la ministre
concernant la Grande-Bretagne vous avez
raison
l'Irlande souhaite supprimer la notion
donc Dora collage mais contre parce
qu'il faut savoir qu'en Grande-Bretagne
le client est pénalisé s'il a recours à
une personne sous contrainte c'est
valable en Irlande on Écosse au Pays de
Galles et en Angleterre or ce que
souhaite les Irlandais puisque du client
existe c'est simplement qu'on enlève
justement contrainte c'est-à-dire que ce
soit pour tout le monde ce que les
autres refusent et ça ne peut être
adopté en Grande-Bretagne que si les
quatre membres de l'Union sont d'accord
c'est justement cette cette solution qui
moi m'aurait convenu
qui m'aurait convenu je mérite une
discussion mais la notion de contrainte
je le répète aurait cet avantage de
pénaliser les clients de personnes qui
sont exploitées et de répondre à la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme qui
explique que le droit ne peut pas porter
à la libre disposition de son corps
c'est jugement de 2007 que j'ai là donc
cette notion de contrainte avait cette
avant aurait cette avantage il répond
aux deux objectifs et je me semblait
qu'on le couplant avec une réécriture
donc de l'article 13 enfin de l'article
215 du Code pénal nous aurions pu avoir
la un texte d'équilibre mais ça
nécessite effectivement que nous ayons
une discussion une discussion précise et
donc pour ce qui me concerne je crois
que en l'état des choses étant donné les
dangers que l'on peut percevoir pour les
personnes prostituées vous savez je
crains fort on voit qu'on est qu'on
inverse véritablement le rôle
actuellement bien sûr la personne
constituées n'ont pas beaucoup de moyens
se défendre enfin elles peuvent quand
même se défendre elles disent qu'elles
sont organisées pour ça quand le client
va je dirais tenir la personne en disant
vous n'aura pas d'argent si moi je ne
viens pas moi je prends des risques pour
venir donc il y a pas de discussion
préalable pas de discussion sur la
prestation pas discussion sur le tarif
pas discussion sur le sur l'endroit où
ça va se produire et donc dans le secret
absolu et il y a rien de pire pour une
prochaine prostituée que se retrouver
par exemple dans le huis clos d'une
pièce seule avec le client donc je pense
je voudrais convaincre que ma position
ce n'est pas du tout que moi je souhaite
défendre le client mais pas du tout
c'est que je souhaite au contraire
pouvoir protéger les personnes
prostituées pour ne pas justement les
mettre en péril et en danger
c'est-à-dire de pas inverser de
transférer ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
avec le racolage dans le cadre de la
palisation du client voilà ce que je
souhaitais dire
merci Monsieur Godefroy madame la
ministre
il y a eu des propositions de fait
donc il y en a qui veulent avancer même
si apparemment nous sommes face
effectivement
pour différents d'ailleurs arguments qui
se contredisent mais avec des avis qui
convergent a priori qui se sont exprimés
parfois donc en défaveur de la
responsabilisation du client mais je ne
doute pas quel article 17 tout le monde
sera pour faire de la prévention
moi je souhaitais juste attirer votre
attention mais je suis sûr que ça ne
vous a pas échappé parce que vous
travaillez sur ce texte depuis très
longtemps
que si ce soir nous ne bougeons en rien
sur cette responsabilisation du client
vous nous offrez on s'offre entre
guillemets
un statu quo et que pour le coup on n'a
pas à ce chamailler je dirais sur les
effets de ce statu quo parce que quel
que soit la position des uns et des
autres ici dans l'hémicycle les mêmes
constats ont été faits à la tribune lors
de la discussion générale
donc là pour le coup nous sommes tous
d'accord et c'est d'ailleurs pour cela
d'ailleurs que quel que soit les bancs
de cette assemblée il a été voté major
très majoritairement tous les
dispositifs justement de sortie sur la
base du volontarisme de la prostitution
de l'accompagnement social
et sanitaire parce que pourquoi un
accompagnement social et sanitaire parce
que ces femmes en majorité des femmes
mais ces hommes aussi même s'ils sont
moins nombreux que les femmes et bien
sont brisées tout simplement et que nous
avons dit et redit les uns et les autres
qu'aujourd'hui l'état de la prostitution
en France c'était quoi
c'est pas comme dans les années 80
aujourd'hui 97%
monsieur Riquier de cette prostitution
c'est des réseaux de traite humaine ce
sont des femmes ce sont des femmes
qui sont majoritairement des femmes donc
qui viennent de l'étranger à qui on
subtilise d'ailleurs le passeport qui
n'ont pas de papier c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que nous avons des battues de
cette question qui sont réduites souvent
à l'état d'esclavage qui sont marqués
physiquement scarifier ou tatouer pour
qu'on puisse les récupérer et les
déplacer au gré des besoins des pays et
des saisons
du nord vers le sud et puis des
témoignages lorsque je suis allé sur le
terrain avec des associations qui sont
d'ailleurs en demande à la fois qui est
en demande sur l'article 13 et qui sont
aussi en demande sur cet article 16 et
bien qui ont du mal à gagner cette
confiance qu'il a gagné au fur et à
mesure et qui à un moment donné les
voies disparaître pendant deux trois
mois parce qu'on les déplace elles
disent qu'elles sont en vacances en fait
ces vacances se sont les héros Center
que vous pouvez trouver en Espagne aux
frontières de la France ou en Italie
c'est ça la réalité et nous la
connaissons tous ici
donc nous sommes en train de débattre et
de prendre des décisions extrêmement
lourdes et graves en connaissant l'état
des lieux et je vous le dis encore une
fois si nous sortons d'ici sans aucune
avancée puisque déjà l'article 13 est
passé mais sur la prévention et sur la
responsabilisation nous avons accepté
donc le statu quo dans notre pays
merci
madame la ministre
madame joyau joyeux est-ce que vous
maintenez
le 31 rectifié bis oui monsieur le
Président je maintiens le 31 rectifié
bis puisque pour
informer nos collègues et à la suite de
la discussion que nous avons eu dans le
31 rectifié mais enfin si vous écoutez
encore et je vous propose de rédiger
ainsi l'article 225-12-1 le fait de
solliciter d'accepter ou d'obtenir des
relations de nature sexuelle d'une
personne qui se livre sous contrainte à
la prostitution et tout le reste sans
changement pour introduire la notion de
contrainte
à mes collègues
qui me disent
mon Dieu si on pénalise le client on va
encore fragiliser la situation la
personne prostituée et qui viennent de
voter le délit dracolage pardon mais
l'effet pire pour le délitorat collage
et de fait je trouve que l'argument ne
tient pas très longtemps et c'est vrai
que là on fixe un interdit on a beaucoup
travaillé beaucoup travaillé sur les
questions de d'hypersexualisation et
tout ce qui va autour il y a une vraie
banalisation du phénomène de la
prostitution dans des films dans des
clips vidéos dans des défilés de mode
Louis Vuitton a fait son défilé sur le
thème de la prostitution et ça ne choque
personne
donc on a quand même parce qu'on est
abolitionniste mais on l'assume mais moi
je l'assume comme tel on a quand même à
fixer effectivement des lignes clairs
dans notre législation donc je vous
propose ce compromis en introduisant la
notion sous contrainte on peut toujours
me dire il va falloir y travailler ça
fait effectivement quelques mois qu'on
travaille sur le sujet donc il serait
peut-être temps de conclure
merci Madame Jouanneau donc on a bien
compris que c'est à l'article 225 tiré
12 du 1 sous contrainte après qui se
livre mais je crois que cette amendement
rectifié bis le 31 est distribué madame
Cohen a demandé l'explication
oui c'est par rapport à la proposition
que vient de faire donc Madame Jouanneau
de susamender en quelque sorte donc
l'amendement et pour ajouter la notion
de contrainte ce qui semble aller dans
le sens si j'ai bien suivi les débats de
ce qui a essayé d'introduire également
jean-Pierre
Godefroy puisque il a dit que s'il y
avait eu plus de temps la notion de
contrainte moi je trouve que là sous
prétexte de compromis dans l'hémicycle
on est quand même en train de ne pas
mesurer ce que vient de dire Madame la
Ministre
c'est-à-dire si on admet d'introduire la
notion de contrainte on renvoie deux
ados le fait qu'il y aurait une
prostitution librement consentie à part
entière
or les chiffres et moi j'ai aussi la
prétention d'avoir une honnêteté
intellectuelle du à ma formation
scientifique psychologique et
parlementaire qui fait que en fait les
chiffres nous montrent que la majorité
des prostituées sont des prostituées qui
sont dans des réseaux et qui sont
véritablement
soumises aux contraintes de réseau
criminels donc laissez pour se mettre
d'accord pour avoir un semblant de
consensus etc
va mettre de faire rentrer dans ce
système où finalement il y aurait une
prostitution librement consentie moi je
suis en plein désaccord avec ça et c'est
pas une position dogmatique c'est une
réalité de ce qu'est le système
prostitutionnel le système
prostitutionnel on l'a dit c'est un
système mafieux
des systèmes qui réduit les femmes et
les exemples ont été donnés à un
véritable esclavage puisqu'on déplace et
on marque ces femmes dans une société où
il y a en France en Europe et dans le
monde un taux de pauvreté cette pauvreté
se décline au féminin c'est quoi le
libre choix c'est quoi le libre choix et
quand on nous dit depuis le début de la
discussion que les réseaux mafieux sont
extrêmement puissants de plus en plus
violents c'est quoi le le libre choix
donc moi je crois qu'on a la
responsabilité politique
d'assumer ce qui se passe réellement la
réalité de la situation et dire la
prostitution est une violence et le
client a à être responsabilisé et en
plus je mets au défi qui compte de
définir ce qu'est la contrainte
comment on va le faire pour définir la
contrainte on va interroger les
prostituées pour savoir si elles ont
librement choisi cette activité mais
elles sont sous la menace elles sont
menacées sur place et leur famille est
menacée alors c'est quoi le pour
quelques pourcentages de femmes et
d'hommes qui choisissent je suis désolé
on fait quand même une exception madame
Benbassa là on essaye de légiférer pour
tout le monde alors que jusqu'à présent
on fait toujours pour la majorité
des lois donc il y a quelque chose là il
y a deux points de mesure moi je suis
vraiment enfin j'attire l'attention du
Sénat ça peut être une porte de sortie
mais en même temps on met le doigt dans
quelque chose de beaucoup plus grave
donc je ne suis pas d'accord pour
introduire cette notion là
d'avoir une suspension de 5 à 10 minutes
puisque de toute évidence les éléments
qui ont été rajoutés
s'ils ne changent pas fondamentalement
le texte amène quand même une approche
très très sensiblement différente je
pense qu'il est bien que chaque groupe
puisse réunir 5 10 minutes
bien merci monsieur je suis sport en 10
minutes
la séance est suspendue
la séance est reprise
monsieur VIAL
qui vous est proposé c'est peut-être que
l'on puisse se prononcer sur
l'amendement rectifié de Madame jounoux
et de telle sorte que en fonction du
vote les deux autres tomberaient
bien si j'ai bien compris vous demandez
la priorité sur l'amendement 31 rectifié
bis
c'est cela absolument merci donc je
demande à vie au gouvernement
merci monsieur le président
je ne vais pas répéter ce que j'ai dit
il y a quelques minutes à savoir que
nous connaissons
donc je ne répéterai pas ce que j'ai dit
sur
précédemment à savoir que nous
connaissons l'état aujourd'hui
de cette prostitution qui est à 97 %
fait partie des réseaux de traite
humaine
avec des conséquences extrêmement
lourdes sur la santé physique et
psychologique des personnes en situation
de prostitution
je note évidemment cet amendement
je tiens à dire qu'il n'est pas
satisfaisant par rapport à l'objectif
proposé
par les amendements précédents et qu'il
certes crée une légère avancée mais qui
ne résoudra pas
c'est à dire la capacité pleine et
entière
des moyens qui nous seront donnés pour
justement lutter efficacement contre les
réseaux et en même temps mettre
permettre justement à ce que et bien ces
femmes en majorité des femmes puissent
être respecté et encore une fois je ne
suis pas sûr du coup que le message soit
extrêmement clair en disant que et bien
l'achat d'un acte sexuel est une
violence et que l'achat d'un acte sexuel
crée aussi l'entretien
de ces réseaux
néanmoins je note une avancée donc je
donnerai un avis du gouvernement qui est
la sagesse
êtes-vous d'accord madame la ministre
sur la priorité demandée par Monsieur
Viviane
c'est ce n'est pas un sous amendement
c'est un amendement rectifié
rectifiez bis
donc vous donnez la priorité
oui bien merci
donc la vie de la Commission
je vais donner plutôt si vous permettez
monsieur le Président non pas la vie de
la commission parce que on s'est pas
réunis mais à mon avis personnel En tant
que rapporteur de la proposition de loi
c'est un avis négatif madame Jouanneau
sur votre sous-amendement parce que si
on parle de message qu'est-ce que cela
voudrait dire il y aurait une
prostitution sous contrainte qui serait
inacceptable et dont le client
l'acheteur serait pénalisé et puis il y
aurait une autre prostitution et là il
n'y aurait pas pénalisation peut pas
enfin moi je ne peux pas accepter ça
même si j'entends bien par votre
proposition enfin sous amendement il est
d'en sortir et je suis d'accord avec
vous pour dire que ça serait difficile
après toutes nos heures de discussions
d'en arriver là à la non pénalisation de
du client mais non seulement je pense
que le message ne serait pas clair il
serait pas juste non plus pour les
personnes prostituées et puis je
considère que nous en sommes nous au
début de notre examen de proposition de
loi au Sénat et je compte sur la navette
qui je l'espère pourra aussi participer
à une clarification donc c'est un avis
défavorable selon moi
donc oui défavorable y a-t-il des
explications de vote
madame Gauthier
madame Jouanno madame Jouanno tout à
l'heure c'était sur l'ordinaire et là il
est rectifié voilà c'est pour cela que
j'ai demandé la vie de la commission
madame la ministre avait donné son avis
auparavant et donc je mets en
explication de vote et je donne la
parole à Madame Gontier Morin oui
nous voterons contre cet amendement
rectifié je crois que il faut bien
évidemment pour se faire une opinion
dessus aussi
indépendamment de ce qu'a dit ma
collègue Laurence Cohen tout à l'heure
le replacer dans le contexte de l'état
de ce que nous avons déjà voté et
modifier dans la loi jusqu'à maintenant
c'est à dire quand même la remise en sel
du racolage la remise en cause de
l'automatie cité le délai qui pour
l'instant est maintenu un an mais qu'il
a été un poil si je puis m'exprimer et
donc dans ce contexte l'introduction de
la notion de contrainte résonne comme un
pisalet une sorte de compromis et
surtout il est il accrédite l'idée comme
cela vient d'être dit qu'il y aurait 1
pourcentage un certain pourcentage de
prostituées qui le ferait de gaieté de
cœur
et sans contrainte alors que justement
le tout le débat montrer que la plupart
d'entre elles le font sous contrainte de
réseau de traite et que
d'autres beaucoup d'autres aussi même si
elles sont elles ne sont pas sous les
faits d'un réseau le font aussi parce
qu'elles sont contraintes
économiquesment d'y avoir recours encore
une fois je ne connais pas une femme qui
n'aimait pas dit infinie oui je oui
d'accord je fais ça parce que je l'ai
choisi mais qui quelque part finit par
dire mais quel mes estimes de moi j'ai
même vu des prostituées qui avec qui le
cachait leurs enfants on a eu des on a
eu des témoignages donc voilà
pour toutes ces raisons écoutez nous
votre rencontre
merci Madame gontivora y a-t-il d'autres
explications de vote
bien j'ai été saisi donc d'une demande
de scrutin public par le groupe UMP sur
l'amendement numéro 31 rectifié bis je
vous rappelle la vie de leur rapporteur
de madame le rapporteur qui est
défavorable la ville du gouvernement qui
est une sagesse plutôt défavorable si
j'ai bien compris madame la ministre
donc il va être procédé au scrutin
public dans les conditions fixées par
l'article 56 du règlement
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
voici les résultats du scrutin numéro
113 sur l'amendement numéro 31 rectifié
bis appelé en priorité nombre de votants
333 nombre de suffrages exprimés 319
pour l'adoption 14 contre 305 le Sénat
n'a pas adopté
je reviens donc sur l'amendement numéro
3 rectifié bis qui avait été présenté
par Madame Cohen
je le mets aux voix
il y a une demande de scrutin public
donc
identique sur le 3 rectifié bis et sur
le 12 rectifier bis à la demande du
groupe
UMP
l'avis de la commission je rappelle a
été défavorable la vie du gouvernement
favorable il va donc être procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 de notre
règlement
ça ne demande
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin éclos
bien donc voici le résultat du scrutin
numéro 114 sur les amendements
identiques numéro 3 rectifié Bisset
numéro 12 rectifier 10 nombre de votants
331 nombre de suffrages exprimés
296 pour l'adoption 107 contre 189 le
Sénat n'a pas adopté
l'article 16 donc reste supprimé
l'article 17 trois amendements faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune un
amendement numéro 4 rectifié bis c'est
Madame Laurence Cohen qu'il présente
moi
sur le est-ce que ça ne tombe pas
l'article 17 à partir du moment où
l'article 16 est tombé
si vous vous mettiez si vous êtes
d'accord ouais c'est pas une histoire
d'être d'accord moi je suis pour la
sensibilisation des des clients et donc
un stage de sensibilisation me semble le
bienvenu mais j'ai l'impression que dans
la logique
législative il y a plus d'objets de de
le mettre mais bon si on le met en le
mets je le défends réglementairement on
doit le mettre je demande l'avis de la
commission
de manière cohérente avec le
rétablissement
la suppression enfin la non-pénilisation
du client puisque cette
article était en complément de la
pénalisation donc par cohérence cette
article tombe
donc les amendements sont retirés
d'accord
donc il tombe puisque
c'est une anime
nous en venons maintenant à l'article 4
qui avait été précédemment réservé
avec deux amendements
identiques faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune
on va dire pareil
et c'est pour cela qu'il avait été
réservé
je mets au voile article 18
qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté et j'ai
omis de mettre aux voix l'article 4 qui
est pour
c'est les amendements qui sont tombés
qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté
l'article 19
il est supprimé je mets au voir
l'article 20 qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté le 21
suppression est maintenu et sur
l'intitulé de la proposition de loi
deux amendements identiques
le 5 rectifié madame Cohen
écoutez le problème c'est que nous
voulions effectivement modifié
l'intitulé en logique et en cohérence
avec ce qu'on a défendu au niveau de mon
groupe depuis le début c'est-à-dire la
lutte contre le système prostitutionnel
à partir du moment où ici au Sénat la
proposition de loi a été carrément
dépecée de son sens en réintroduisant le
délit dracolage et en ne réintroduisant
pas la pénalisation de l'acte sexuel
tarifé il était peut-être un peu vain de
maintenir un amendement pour modifier
l'intitulé de de la loi
parce que les moyens ne sont pas donnés
pour lutter contre le système
prostitutionnel donc nous retirons notre
amendement merci Madame Cohen madame
meunier sur le vin rectifié
madame Blondin
même
chose cours de sortie et un projet
d'insertion sociale et professionnel
donc voilà
donc il est retiré
madame meunier vous avez demandé la
parole
oui un peu plus parler de système
prostitutionnel puisqu'il y a une
dualité entre proxénète et personne
prostituées donc je pense que il faut
retirer en tout cas ça a plus lieu
d'être
bien Madame la Ministre
merci monsieur le Président ce seront
mes derniers mots je regrette
effectivement que nous puissions changer
le titre de cette loi puisque au final
ce qui ressort des débats et des votes
fait que effectivement ce n'est pas la
lutte contre le système prostitutionnel
mais le statu quo qui est décidé ce soir
nous en avons une analyse précise je
l'ai déjà dit donc mais je tenais aussi
à remercier
les unes et les autres de leur
participation au débat mais
malheureusement je regrette que nous
n'ayons pas les outils nécessaires pour
lutter contre le système prostitutionnel
pour permettre justement aux prostituées
de sortir de de cette de cette situation
de violence de contraintes et mais tout
cela se fait sous les yeux des
Françaises et des Français merci
merci Madame la Ministre
la meunier
et une
suspense
la séance est suspendue pour 10 minutes
la séance est reprise
bien je vais mettre
je vais mettre au bois l'ensemble de la
proposition de loi
y a-t-il des demandes d'explication de
vote
monsieur roquet
le groupe RDSE regrette que le statu quo
dégagé par la commission spéciale n'est
pas été respectée il s'agissait de mon
équilibre nous rappelerons une nouvelle
fois comme la fait mon collègue amis
Guillaume Marnell dans la discussion
générale plusieurs principes sur
lesquels nous fontons notre position
tout à la fois des lits de raccordage
passif et à la période du client le
bénéf le délit du bilan du délit de
passif et désastreux 12 ans après sa
mise en place des lits n'ont pas réglé
les problèmes et qui peut en dé cibler
il a engendre la contrario pervers tels
que l'aggravation de la précarité des
personnes prostituées il renforçant des
réseaux mafieux il est revenu valu
à ceux qui souhaitaient le conserver
retravailler sa définition car
aujourd'hui l'absence de définition
précise du raccordage passif permet
l'arrestation de toute personne soit
seule base de la tenue vestimentaire
comme cela a été rappelé double peine
qui touche la victime qui s'est dit la
Constitution
favorise la stigmatisation des
prostituées la réduction des chiffres de
la prostitution ne figure même pas parmi
les bienfaits attendus de cette
infraction ainsi énorme des personnes
mis en cause pour en collage par la
police municipale la CCI de baisser
depuis 2003 en 2004
3290 personnes prostituées des mises en
cause ce chiffre passé en 18008 et à
1340-2009 à Paris le taux de défairement
la cessé de diminuer passant de 38% en
2005 à 0% en 2009 le phénomène n'avons
pas disparu il est seulement caché dans
ses apparitions parloignement des
prostituées hors des centres urbain
à quel prix celui de la santé la
sécurité prostituée tout à l'heure qui
sont susceptibles d'être victime
d'agression et d'attaque voir le
chantage de la part d'individus
malintentionnés la logique est
répressive est un contresens il est
impossible rétablir le déshydratoire
passif tout en créant un accompagnant
social et sanitaire pour des prostituées
auxquelles l'on confère le statut de
délinquant nous regrettons ainsi que le
Sénat est rétabli d'une courte voie par
voie par 162 comme 61 le délit de
raquage passif qui a fait preuve de sol
l'efficacité c'est une pure mesure
d'affichage aux effets pervers avérés
nous soyons à contrario le maintien de
la suppression de la pénalisation des
clients des biologiques de paralyse des
formes législatives a été prise par la
Suède en 99 mais elle n'a pas été suivie
des défis inspirés miraculeux cela a été
rappelé une professeure
l'article intitulé
prostitution Stockholm la ville ou le
client est invisible
le raisonnement des abolitionistes est
simple taré la demande c'est abolir la
prostitution si nous partageons
l’objectif de cette analyse le
partageons pas pour autant son essence
pour des raisons de bon sens et de prise
en compte de la réalité la Constitution
ne sera pas établie abolie par ce canal
mais elle sera remis encore plus
précaire pénaliser les clients c'est
exposer les prostituées à la violence de
même manière qu'avec le dolidracolage
passif qui a fait long feu toutes les
associations féministes le répète et
l'évaluation garde des sceaux et
sénateurs Robert valenter
devant notre commission spéciale et
aucun de cela ne peut être soupçonné de
complaisance avec des réseaux mafieux ou
même de naïveté sur la condition sociale
du client et sanitaire de ces personnes
ton pénaliser le client est donc niveau
de solution ça ne marcherait pas on ne
décrète pas la fin de la prostitution
par une décision légale il faut mener
les politiques de prévention et accomp
agner de mieux possible ce qu'ici libre
constitués mais aussi clients il faut
enfin permettre à ces jeunes femmes et à
ces hommes qui souhaitent dans la
prostitution que la puissance publique
et les protège les soutiennent le groupe
RDSE salut certes inégal et insuffisante
sur le plan des mesures sanitaires et
sociales ainsi que ce point
d'appréhension
à l'heure où la prostitution n'est qu'un
maillon de la longue chaîne à traite
humaine et où la proportion des
personnes étrangères atteints 90% pour
la prostitution cela publique
l'abolition de la traite humaine plus
générale ne peut résulter que des fois
globaux en matière de coopération
européenne et internationale afin de
tarir les riches filantes de la misère
exploitée par les réseaux mafieux enfin
un regret nous on peut parler de la
constitution des mineurs qui prend des
proportions inquiétantes évidemment
inacceptables et qui nécessiterait un
traitement particulier et adapté alors
même si les chers collègues opposé tout
à la fois au délit de raccord et passif
et à la pénalisation du client soucieux
de politique active d'aide et le soutien
prostitué la grande majorité des membres
du RDSE s'affinera donc sur ce texte
proposé à l'issue des travaux de ce jour
en séance publique
merci Monsieur Ruquier madame Cohen
monsieur le Président nous nous sommes
au regret au niveau du groupe communiste
républicains et citoyen de dire que nous
allons voter contre cette proposition de
loi parce que comme j'ai eu l'occasion
de le dire elle a été complètement
dénaturée en ce sens où les quatre
piliers ne sont plus présents réellement
dans cette proposition de loi je vous
rappelle qu'il s'agissait de la
protection et de l'accompagnement des
prostituées prévention pour sortir de ce
système prostitutionnel lutte contre les
réseaux et puis pénalisation de l'acte
tarifé donc responsabilisation du client
c'est pour moi et pour nous un
rendez-vous manqué qui entérine comme la
forge justement dit Madame la Ministre
un statu quo ce qui n'est pas acceptable
et ce qui à mon sens il y a notre sens
n'aurait pas dû être le signe donné par
le Sénat contenu du temps de latence
pour qu'il soit enfin mis à l'ordre du
jour je pense que c'est d'autant plus
dommageable que les associations Premier
ministre et abolitionniste ont permis
par leur engagement de franchir de
nouvelles étapes c'est à dire que la
prostitution aujourd'hui n'est plus
considérée comme un problème individuel
mais vraiment comme une question sociale
sociétale et politique et donc nous
avons raté ce rendez-vous en tant que
parlementaire puisque nous avons
fait en sorte qu'il y ait un espèce de
retour en arrière disant en arrière en
réintroduisant même à une voix près mais
en réintroduisant la pénalisation
des prostituées en les considérant comme
des criminels puisque on a réintroduit
le délit de racolage et en refusant de
pénaliser l'acte sexuel tarifé qui reste
pour moi
un moyen de responsabiliser le client
même si effectivement à lui tout seul il
n'est pas suffisant et je suis
particulièrement choquée de voir que il
y a tant de blocages euh quant à cette
responsabilisation du client tant
d'entêtement à vouloir considérer que
finalement il n'est pas acteur du
système prostitutionnel tant
d'entêtement aussi à ne pas voir
concrètement que la prostitution est une
violence extrême infligée aux femmes que
les prostituées sont majoritairement
entre les mains de réseau qui sont
extrêmement violents qui draine
énormément d'argent puisque la
prostitution est un marché juteux comme
sont les ventes d'armes et la drogue et
que je trouve que nous n'avons pas été à
la hauteur au niveau du Sénat de cette
réalité de cette violence et nous
n'avons pas donné le message qui
s'imposait et que les prostituées
majoritairement attendaient et c'est
pour toutes ces raisons là que je nous
ne pouvons pas voter cette proposition
de loi alors que nous étions en soutien
en renfort à la proposition de loi
proposée par le gouvernement et voter à
l'assemblée
nationale je veux réaffirmer ici parce
que il faut bien s'écouter les uns les
autres ce que j'ai essayé de faire c'est
que la position que je défends n'est pas
une position morale
ni personnel ni au nom de mon groupe je
trouve que nous n'avons pas mis en avant
le fait et les pourtant les études de
récentes nous n'avons pas suffisamment
pris en compte que le client de la
prostitution c'est monsieur tout le
monde et puis en fait lui-même est
victime d'un formatage social ou la
masculinité la virilité passe par la
domination que la société disent aux
clients que le corps n'est pas une
marchandise doit permettre à ce client
de se responsabiliser voir à envisager
son rapport aux autres d'une façon
différente et certainement plus
libératrice aussi pour lui pénaliser le
client serait donc pour moi un acte
fondateur d'une nouvelle liberté pour
les femmes et les hommes en aidant à
libérer les uns comme les autres du
système prostitutionnel afin d'avancer
sur le chemin d'une société
d'émancipation humaine donc on est bien
loin de choix moralisateur donc pour
toutes ces raisons pour ce ces
rendez-vous manqués au niveau du Sénat
mon groupe votera contre cette
proposition de loi telle que nous est
présentée aujourd'hui
merci Madame Cohen madame Lepage
mais merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre chers collègues ce texte est
issu d'un long travail parlementaire
commencé en septembre 2010 par les
députés Daniel Bousquet et Guy Geoffroy
il a donné lieu à de nombreux débats où
chacun a pu intervenir les personnes
prostituées les associations
spécialisées les pouvoirs publics la
presse les clients et l'ensemble de la
population et jusqu'à présent il
dépassait les clivages politiques
aujourd'hui le texte sur lequel nous
devons nous prononcer n'a plus grand
chose à voir avec celui sur lequel nous
avons travaillé et les mots de François
Hollande résonnent bien étrangement la
je cite la prostitution est une des
expressions les plus frappantes de ces
inégalités et violence qui perdurent
dans notre société et dans le monde si
chacun est libre de disposer de son
corps les droits humains et la dignité
humaine sont incompatibles avec le fait
qu'une personne est le droit de disposer
librement du corps d'une autre personne
parce qu'il a payé enfin une citation
en effet notre Assemblée a opéré un
véritable rétropédalage seul et coupable
la personne prostituée c'est à dire dans
près de 90% des cas la femme exploitée
par un réseau international de
proxénétisme le client dont la demande
explique justement l'asservissement de
cette femme et lui blanc comme neige on
marche sur la tête la prostitution n'est
pas le plus vieux métier du monde comme
le répète certains en revanche si bien
l'une des activités les plus violentes
du monde et l'expression de domination
multiple or notre rôle de législateur
est un moyen de pallier autant que faire
se peut les inégalités et les rapports
de domination je ne puis cautionner une
entreprise d'avilissement de la personne
humaine d'exploitation commerciale de la
précarité de en marchant fondé sur la
domination et je me refuse à assimiler
la prostitution à une ultime liberté des
femmes à disposer de leur corps sordide
cache sexe bien utile à ceux qui ne
souhaitent pas œuvrer à une société plus
égalitaire et progressiste n'oublions
pas comme le rappelle Françoise Héritier
que je cite dire que les femmes ont le
droit de se vendre c'est masquer que les
hommes ont le droit de les acheter je
Réfut tout autant l'accusation si
commode de mer la morale liberticide la
sexualité de chacun au sein de sa vie
privée à les meilleures raisons d'être
multi variées originales dès lors
qu'elle est libre et s'accompagne donc
d'un désir partagé dans ce domaine aussi
nous avons droit à d'autres rapports que
se guider par la loi du plus fort
nous devions vivre un moment important
manifester la volonté du Sénat de
répondre aux aspirations de la société
vous avez pu lire encore hier d'ailleurs
de nombreuses tribunes signées par des
médecins des associations d'aide aux
victimes et de lutte contre les
violences sexuelles et sexistes qui
témoignent de la violence intrinsèque de
la prostitution mais aussi des tribunes
signées par des intellectuels des jeunes
des mouvements syndicaux plus de 200
mères et conseillers municipaux qui
demandent une dépénalisation des
prostituées et pardon et une
responsabilisation des clients
la proposition de loi sur laquelle nous
devons nous prononcer et dénaturer et
tourne le dos à la conception française
à positionniste vieille de plus de 50
ans les débats se sont focalisés sur la
pénalisation du client et voilà le
navrant résultat par son adoption nous
enverrions un message des plus
rétrogrades à toutes les prostituées et
à nos voisins européens y compris ceux
qui ont fait le choix de la
réglementation et en estime aujourd'hui
le désastreux bilan en termes de
développement des réseaux et de
précarisation des prostituées
la mise en place du parcours de sortie
de la prostitution et la volonté
réitérer de lutter contre les réseaux
conduiront cependant la majorité du
groupe socialiste a s'abstenir mais à
titre personnel je voterai contre le
texte
merci Madame Lepage
madame meunier
madame la ministre chers collègues moi
aussi j'ai un goût amer en prononçant
ces quelques mots pour expliquer mon
vote je m'exprime à titre personnel
autant je me réjouissais dans la
discussion générale du vote qui allait
se faire qu'elle est grandir et qui
allait nous faire grandir sur une
question difficile certes mais qui comme
cela a été dit
participe aux questions d'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes donc cela a été
dit l'esprit de la loi qui était
équilibré qui avait un message clair et
précis à la fois
pour les réseaux et les
proxénètes pour les personnes
prostituées et pour les clients et bien
ce soir après les votes qui ont eu lieu
n'est plus du tout dans cet équilibre
donc j'en suis bien déçue très attristée
et plus que un statu quo moi j'y vois
une régression et un recul qui nous fait
revenir
aux années 2003 donc un goût amer qui me
fera ne pas voter ce texte mais je veux
être
positif constructive et je me dis que
dans son parcours le parcours de ce
texte première lecture aussi au Sénat
tout n'est pas perdu moi je crois et je
veux croire que nos collègues à
l'Assemblée nationale
retrouveront
le texte originel avec notre concours
monsieur le Président de la commission
spéciale car je pense que nous ne
baisserons pas les bras d'une manière ou
d'une autre nous retrouverons contact
sur ce texte pour le faire progresser
l'intérêt général et surtout en faveur
des personnes prostituées parce que ce
que je veux dire aussi c'est que par nos
votes je doute aussi des mesures et la
mise en oeuvre des mesures que nous
avons décidé pour l'accompagnement et la
protection des personnes prostituées et
donc en cela je ne voterai pas et je
voterai contre ce texte qui sort de nos
débats et l'AS qui ne reflète pas du
tout le travail effectué depuis ces
derniers mois
merci Madame Monnier
monsieur le Président de la commission
spéciale
ministre mes chers collègues et sans
vouloir rallonger les débats un mot il a
été effectivement exprimé par beaucoup
une déception de voir effectivement
le point auquel nous aboutissons au
terme de ces nombreux échanges
je peux dire d'ailleurs que pour partie
je rejoins même si mon groupe prendra
une position différente les propos
exprimés par madame le rapporteur
puisque lors des nombreux échanges qu'il
y a eu autant sur la le rétablissement
du délit de recollage que sur la
pénalisation du client nous avons vu les
nombreuses expressions et qui ont été
avancées et qui montrent que de toute
évidence malgré le travail important qui
ait été fait par la mission spéciale
nous sommes aujourd'hui sur je dirais
pas une confrontation un affrontement
dans des positions différentes car nous
avons vu que sur beaucoup de notamment
l'essentiel c'est-à-dire essayer de à
défaut d'éradiquer de pouvoir s'engager
résolument dans la voie de l'attaque des
réseaux de ce que cela représente il y a
du travail devant nous pour que autant
sur ce que nous avons soulevé dans le
cas du rétablissement et du
délit de dracolage pour ça que j'ai
quelques difficultés quand j'entends
parler que on fait des prostituées et
des criminels les non non les mots les
mots ont un sens et en matière pénale et
criminel celui qui fait un crime voilà
et que je sache le délir de règleage est
un délit non mais il faut il faut il
faut donner aux mots le sens qu'ils ont
surtout quand on parle
d'infraction de délit et de crimes voilà
donc je l'indique parce que mais les
échanges je crois ont été de bonne
qualité
je vous dis très sincèrement la même
ministre il y a sur beaucoup de mesures
des oppositions qui se sont faites n'ont
pas tendance dans le fond des mesures
que dans la portée qu'il était attendu
de celle-ci et je crois qu'effectivement
cela était dit nous sommes dans un texte
et qui n'est pas sous le coup de
l'urgence et qui pourra bénéficier d'un
aller-retour avec l'Assemblée nationale
j'espère que sur beaucoup de points qui
ont été évoqués ce soir et sur lesquels
nous avons vu leur insuffisance va leur
faiblesse nous pourrons progresser cela
étant c'est une étape et donc le groupe
UMP se prononcera favorablement à ce
texte en espérant que les débats qui
suivront y compris pourquoi ne pas
envisager
des discussions avec l'Assemblée
nationale sur un sujet aussi fondamental
qui est celui de l'honneur de la
condition humaine sur lequel il faut que
nous puissions avancer ensemble
merci monsieur le Président y a-t-il
d'autres explications madame Benbassa
merci monsieur le Président ce texte de
loi s'étant trompé de cible dès le début
a fini sous une forme prohibitionniste
c'était son sort si nous voulons aider à
l'émancipation des femmes il faut leur
donner la possibilité de le faire en
s'attaquant par exemple avec vigueur au
réseau en investissant des fonds
suffisants pour aider celles qui veulent
sortir de la prostitution et en
prévoyant en amont l'éducation des
jeunes à l'égalité femme homme et
surtout en faisant de sorte que
l'inégalité sociale n'aboutissent pas à
l'exercice de la prostitution ni la
répression ni la vertu comme vous le
savez n'ont jamais réglé la question de
la pauvreté ni de la misère mon groupe
ne votera pas ce texte détricoté merci
madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président
les derniers mots pour résumer la
situation de ce texte à l'issue des
débats et bien les prostituées sont
toujours des personnes délinquantes le
client est toujours roi les réseaux ont
de belles heures devant eux malgré le
travail acharné de nos forces de l'ordre
et aussi de nos représentants de la
justice quand au gouvernement et bien il
continue à travailler il continue à
travailler auprès des associations que
je tiens à saluer ce soir ces
associations qui vont continuer à faire
un travail difficile avec des personnes
qui ont peur qui se cachent et qui
ne pourront pas dans ces conditions et
parce que le statut court a été décidé
encore ce soir ne pourront pas
bénéficier avec les meilleurs
les meilleurs dispositions même de ce
que vous avez voté dans les avancées
d'accompagnement en termes sanitaires et
sociales donc je remercie permettez-moi
aussi de remercier et bien l'ami prof à
mes côtés qui travaillent aussi sur ces
questions et encore un salut aux
associations merci de ces débats et en
tous les cas c'est bientôt une nouvelle
lecture à l'Assemblée nationale
j'imagine avec de nouvelles avancées
merci madame la ministre
je mets donc au voile ensemble de la
proposition de loi dont la commission
spéciale ainsi rédigé l'intitulé
proposition de loi visant à la lutte
contre la traite des êtres humains à des
fins d'exploitation sexuelles contre le
proxénétisme et pour la compagnement des
personnes prostituées
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe
UMP sur l'ensemble de la proposition de
loi il va donc être procédé au scrutin
public
voici le résultat du scrutin numéro 115
sur l'ensemble de la proposition de loi
nombre de votants 335 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 209 pour l'adoption
165 contre 44 le Sénat a adopté
voilà vous avez donc pu suivre l'examen
et le vote de la proposition de loi sur
la lutte contre le système
prostitutionnel un texte profondément
modifié par les sénateurs puisqu'ils ont
supprimé la pénalisation du client et
réintroduit le délit de recollage le
texte devrait maintenant repartir en
deuxième lecture à l'Assemblée nationale